you also celebrated this is nice your
fourth anniversary yeah with your lovely
wife to win a new so that's gradually
thank you very much very nice yeah you
know the the first three anniversaries
were very lavish you like what would you
do you would take her out to a great
meet a fancy dinner a nice restaurant
huge you know think flowers yeah Dazzler
got dancing probably yeah and then we
got the baby now so this year I got home
I picked a single flower out of the
neighbor's garden I walked in I was like
happy anniversary it's just like thanks
and then we both passed out on our faces
yeah yeah welcome to Parenthood
did you enjoy that it was good enjoy
that that's gonna get it's gonna get
much easier in about 18 years now this
is your wife a very very talented
musician yes and so I'm figuring if you
if I visited your house had been invited
but if I went to your house probably
great just musical instruments all over
the house I'm imagining right because
she plays you any instruments piano and
harp especially oh really
yeah we have multiple harps in the home
she plays harps that's yeah yeah yeah
yeah
that's so cool like a champ she plays
them yeah Gert if somebody breaks in and
they have to get through the house in
the dark they knock over our prey you
know they're there yeah
yeah yeah that's the most paranoid
thinking I've ever heard perfect burglar
alarm that sounds like angels are having
an orgy down there so wait you got all
these harps in the house does she does
she play the harp for you she plays well
not for me but she's you know she's a
pro so she plays all the time to
practice and she's writing and stuff and
before we ever met I was a huge fan of
her music so now it's incredible for me
when she plays I just sort of go and lie
down on the floor and just Zen out while
she plays it's really great I'm just
trying to picture you obviously very
much in love with your your wife and
listening to her play the harp it's like
the expression you would have on your
face right when you hear her playing the
harp can we see that now can we see what
is it imagine you're at home and you're
lying there and you're on the floor and
your wife's practicing her harp and
you're just listening and we'll we'll
play a little art music yeah I don't
know put you in the mood I just want to
see what it is you're like
[Music]
why'd you take it there why'd you take
it I'm very yeah oh you're not hey man
we're talking about my wife who are you
to tell me what I see spiritually I
didn't realize you were in favor of the
travel ban me horrifying yeah you took
the belt out she's great at music yeah
you